hello everyone a lot of you had asked me
to show a game played by Ramesh Babu
pregnant and the world's youngest
international master but as I'm not
really sure if I'm pronouncing his name
right I just call him Prabhu and well as
he is the youngest international master
in the world in 2013 he won the under 8
years old world championship in 2015 he
won the under 10 years old a World
Championship and in this game this was
played last year in 2016 somewhere in
October he was I believe he was either
10 years old or or just had his 11th
birthday but well it doesn't really
matter either he was 10 or or just
turned 11 his opponent is axel Bachman a
grandmaster from Paraguay and at the
time this game was played he was rated
around 2600 and 40 points I believe so
quite an opponent for a 10 11 year-old
so let's see this game axel Bachmann is
white and Prabhu is black I will have d4
nice to have six nice to a bishop for
sorry g6 and Knight to c3 and I don't
really think that the this move order
has a name so I don't think this really
this is an opening
we have d5 Queen to d2 Bowman is
immediately preparing this Bishop d6
move we have Bishop to g7 by Praga
Bishop to h6 and the prog of castles we
have Bishop captures on g7 team captures
on g7 and we have queenside castle and
immediately c5 is played and in this
position mr. Baughman plays III but
there's there's really no point in
capturing this see c5 pawn with for
example D captures on c5 as Queen to a5
would be played and then this Knight
captures on d5 would result in Queen
captures on a2 and well this would be
after Queen to c3 this would be an okay
position for black to play so instead of
going for this after c5 he played III
we have a ninth the c6 and well in this
position Bachmann plays f3 maybe a
better move was Knight to f3
because after f3 Praga plays c4 and now
this F to remove isn't allowing his
Knight into the game also the c-4 move
blocks this bishop from coming into the
game so White's next move is pretty much
forced he does have to play e4 and break
open the position so we have e 4 and now
Prager plays b5 and well white has white
has a couple of options here he can
capture well of course this phone on b5
would knife capture some b5 or he can go
for he captures and e-file let's see
what happens if he captures this pawn
and b5 after night after some b5 well
the knight isn't defending this efore
pawn so let me simply capture on e4 now
but even better would be something like
rook to b8 attacking this night and
after Knight to c3 Queen to b6 with with
some pressure to this b b2 pawn white
would defend this 0 would be 3 or Knight
to a4 but the black would be completely
fine in this position
so after b5 Bachmann decided to play it
captures on d5 and here Prague doesn't
capture on d5 he plays Knights to be for
preparing Queen to a5 and well again
White has a couple of a couple of
options here obviously he can capture
this night on night and be sorry pawn
and b5 playing g4 would be okay for
example or developing this night with
night - g - e - but my buffman decides
to go for the sharpest line he plays
Knight captures on b5 and well this of
course allows Knight captures an 8 you
would check we are king to be 1 and now
it seems that this night is lost
he can't retreat as the Queen is
covering B 4 and a 5 and the black Queen
can go to a5 to defend the night because
the white queen is covering a 5 so well
the knight in fact can be defended and
he's defended with Queen captures on d5
and now if the knight is captured King
captures and a2
you get simply c3 would discover check
from the Queen and also you're attacking
the White Queen and e2 so after Queen to
d5 Bachman tries Knights to a3 and well
here we have c3 now attacking the Queen
and the knight is defending this pawn on
c3 so the Queen cannot capture it we
have B captures on c3 and now rook to b8
would check there really isn't a lot of
moves y can play he could play he could
even block this with for example Bishop
to b5 but this doesn't really accomplish
anything simple a6 would would be
killing here so we have King to a 1 and
now Queen to a5 and this is well this is
this is terrible
the queen is attacking the knight and a3
knight Knight captures and c3 is coming
they're all all sorts of threats in the
position so progress practically forcing
Bachman to capture the night on a 2 so
he does he plays King captures on a 2
and we have Knight to d5 now again with
a terrible threat of Knight captures and
c3 for example if something like c-4 is
played for example white wants to
exchange Queens simply Knight to c3 with
check and White has to give up the Queen
with Queen Queen captures on c3 because
if King to a 1 that's the only move for
King simply Queen captures on a3 and
this is checkmate
so after Knight d5 Bachman tries one
more defensive resource key plays Knight
and night Stewie - now the night is
defending the c3 pawn but here Prager
plays Bishop to e6 and this is move 18
of the game and in this move in this
position axle Bachman resigned the game
as there is no defense whatever white
plays black is black is simply winning
for example c4 and now again trying this
idea to exchange Queens Knight to be
fourth check and again White has to give
up the Queen if he doesn't if he plays
something like him to be too nice to d3
check this is a double check from the
night and the row can be eight King
and rub the b2 with check only movie
screen to a-1 and Queen captures on a3
with checkmate but Bachman didn't allow
any of this so after Bishop to e6
he simply resigned the game and I
remember when this game was played it
immediately became famous as well every
every chess portal or chess blog or just
website I showed the game and well young
pregnant and I was giving a lot of
interviews as this was quite astonishing
for like I said I'm not sure if it if he
was 10 or just turned 11 when this game
was played but still he defeated player
rated twenty six hundred and forty so
yeah quite an amazing feat for for such
a young player and I don't think his I
don't think he has his Grandmaster title
yet but definitely he will have it soon
as he's quite a remarkable player so him
in the description below I will put a
link where you can watch him analyze
this game he doesn't talk much but he
does bring out some interesting ideas so
yeah I would like to thank Tony maws
guitar and Adam doyack for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and yeah as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon